foreign
[Applause]
speak up
bring your whole selves to work
be the difference that you want to see
sound familiar
starting to sound very familiar to quite
a few employees
now many leaders are asking voices of
difference to speak up
and that's because what gets said and
what doesn't
in our workplaces has a huge consequence
for things like ethical conduct
Innovation inclusion
Talent retention
so more and more employees at the moment
are starting to speak up about social
and environmental concerns
and this is great but it's not always
going quite to plan for everybody
a finance director I've been working
with he's been asking his employees to
speak up for quite a while and now
they've started to
so they're saying okay
let's talk about race
let's talk about gender equity
climate change I want to talk about that
modern slavery
and this Finance director came to me
somewhat stunned and said you know Megan
I've got to admit when I ask people to
speak up
I was kind of thinking that I'd get more
transparency around compliance issues
and a few good ideas
I didn't really Bank on getting
everything else
but this is an era of employee activism
and that's great but why does it end up
on the front pages of the newspaper for
the wrong reasons sometimes
employees walking out getting fired
taking to social media
organizational reputations destroyed or
investors seeking change at the top of
organizations
so my research over the past few years
with John Higgins has involved
interviewing hundreds of activists and
leaders
and activist leaders
and our works in service of enabling
voices of difference
to make a difference in the workplace
now today I'm just going to draw out
four key findings and I'm also going to
go through a few do's and don'ts for
leaders who want to navigate this
territory
proactively productively
so let me start with a question
when I say the word activist
what comes to mind
what images
what thoughts what assumptions
well we've asked thousands of people
that question and I can safely say that
the words activist and activism are
loaded terms
they mean everything from
progress and courage and passion and
change
through to protest Rebellion violence
it's quite cool to be labeled an
activist in some parts of the world and
in relation to some issues
and in other parts of the world and in
relation to other issues being labeled
an activist is life-threatening
so we need to understand
the assumptions and the associations
that we bring to activism because of
course that affects how we respond to it
I was working with the board of a
healthcare organization and in the
coffee break they started to talk about
an employee
who'd been pretty vocal on the internal
comms challenge channels about climate
change and he was quite uh critical of
what the organization had been doing
it was really interesting because some
of the executives labeled him as a
troublemaker
kind of wanted to get rid of him
but there were a few executives
that saw him as a Trailblazer and
actually a couple that wanted to invite
him into the board to educate them
okay
so we've got to the first key point for
our leaders is to understand that
activism is in the eye of the beholder
as ruchika toshian uh author and
activist told us what looks like
Rebellion to you
is another person's basic human rights
so the first thing you've got to do is
really become aware of the kind of
assumptions
and judgments that you and your
colleagues bring to activism
in order that you can then respond with
more awareness and more mindfulness
second point leaders can find themselves
in an optimism bubble we sometimes call
it a delusion bubble
as you get more senior
you overestimate the degree to which
other people are speaking up
you overestimate your approachability
and you overestimate your listening
skills
and that all means that you
underestimate
the strength of feeling that might exist
with some of your employees now one of
the key reasons for this is something we
call Advantage blindness
so when we have the labels and titles
that conveys status and Authority in a
particular context like hierarchy for
example
we're often the last person to realize
the impact that those labels have on how
other people are able to speak up to us
in fact it's not until we don't have
those labels that we can kind of look at
them and go gosh they make a difference
to how people can voice around here
so this this point for leaders is all
about understanding you know are you in
one of these optimism bubbles are you a
bit detached how do you know what your
employees
find matters in their organizations do
you how
I was talking to the head of a retail
organization and she was saying that her
leadership teams spend a lot of time in
stores yeah listening
and she said something I thought was
really interesting she said you can't
delegate your listening responsibility
to pulse surveys
yeah you've got to show up with your
ears wide open
so what this means is don't assume you
know what matters
you know sharpen your antennae try and
figure out we've written about lots of
ways that you can do that but underlying
all of those methods is an understanding
that it's almost inevitable that you're
detached a bit and you need to do a lot
more work actually to really find out
what matters to employees
so third point
inaction is as political as action we've
met quite a few leaders that say that
they're neutral on certain issues or
apolitical
there's no such thing
our inaction on things like climate
change is as political as our action
I was working with a HR director in the
construction industry right at the
moment where a competitor
had said some fairly disparaging things
about women in the industry
it's a huge controversy and this HR
Director really didn't want to get
involved he just wanted to avoid the
conflict stay out of it but his
employees wouldn't let him because his
silence would have communicated
complicity
now what I am not saying even though I'm
often accused of saying it what I am not
saying is that therefore you need to act
on every issue that's out there
of course you don't and of course you
can't it's infeasible what I am saying
as a leader is that you need to make
conscious coherent authentic choices
about what you will make a stand on and
what you won't
and do that in conjunction with your
stakeholders and of course your
employees are one of your key
stakeholders there
final point is that it's useful to
understand what your employees think
your response has been to activist
issues so far
not what you think it is but what do
your employees think it's been
and in our research we came up with a
kind of taxonomy of different leadership
responses it starts with non-existent
or activism what activism
we talked to a chief executive in the
manufacturing industry
and Midway through our conversation I
asked him about climate change and his
strategy and stance on environmental
issues and he looked at me utterly
baffled
it was nowhere on the agenda
now that looks increasingly
inconceivable actually but it certainly
still happens
and then you get suppression
or let's just expel those voices before
it spreads
now this is where leaders explicitly
silence or implicitly because employees
know that if they do speak up it'll
probably cost them their next promotion
or indeed if they do speak up they might
be ignored we surveyed just over 3 000
employees in a recent project and just
over one in five employees expect to be
ignored if they speak up about wider
social and environmental concerns
after that comes something that we call
facadism
or let's just say the right things
this is When leaders make proclamations
about what's important and they may even
say what they're going to do about it
but nothing happens
in the wake of George Floyd's murder
there were many organizations that made
statements of support for the black
lives matter movement
when the American Marketing Association
investigated things shortly after they
found that less than one in ten had made
any concrete changes
then you get to something we call
defensive engagement
or let's just do what the lawyers tell
us
now this is where leaders do engage on a
topic
but only because they really have to
again working with a senior team
recently in the farmer industry the
issue of diversity and inclusion came up
on the agenda it was dealt with in about
five minutes
and essentially they said let's send
everybody on a course and count the
number of women
that was kind of as far as it got they
did the bare minimum
and then there's a step change to what
we call dialogic engagement
or let's sit down listen and learn
and the reason why it's a step change is
because leaders here know that they
don't know the answer and they really
want to find out what they don't know
okay so we uh we talked to an
entrepreneur who had taken over uh ex-uk
car manufacturing plant
and the workers there were very upset
about working conditions and so this
entrepreneur decided in general
mcchrystal's terms to share information
until it was almost illegal
in other words he got in the employees
and opened up the books
shared information and shared decision
making with them about what they needed
to do
and that was a vastly different
leadership style from the ones that
they've been used to
now right at the end we've got
stimulating activism this is When
leaders say let's be the activist
this is the Ben and Jerry's and the
patagonias of the world and they recruit
activists they promote activists they
keep hold of activists in their
organizations
now there's many things that I could
take out from this taxonomy let me draw
just two key learnings out here
first of all you need to know where your
employees think your response has been
so far not where you think it's been
because guess what let's go back to that
optimism bubble the more senior you are
the more likely you are to think that
you're in dialogue
but if I ask a more Junior employee
they're more likely to say no it's a
facade
or even actually I'm scared to speak up
the second key point is dialogue is
messy
it's jam-packed full of vulnerability
ambiguity
disagreement that's why leaders try and
avoid it so much
but you can't avoid it any longer that's
not a sustainable strategy so we need to
get far better at experimenting
at expecting Fallout
about learning from mistakes
so in summary we are entering an age of
employee activism
and if we can't or won't hear voices of
difference in our organization we need
to consider that
like the canary in the coal mine
in other words a signal of danger
because if we can't talk about stuff
that matters to us
but that we differ on
that spells disaster in our
organizations for things like ethical
conduct Innovation inclusion Talent
retention performance
so maybe in the face of some of these
enormous social and environmental issues
maybe we're finally starting to reassess
what good leadership looks like
maybe we're starting to see leadership
as activism
and in doing that maybe we'll enable
voices of difference to make a
difference in the workplace by allowing
them to speak truth to power
thank you
[Applause]